8 juin prochain marlène schiappa
publiera son nouveau livre c'est une
bonne situation sa ministre quelle plume
prolifique baudelaire on a compté depuis
son arrivée au gouvernement en 2017 en
1779 jours donc marlène schiappa rope en
dudit livre 2006 pages au total alors je
n'ai pas encore eu la primeur de lire le
prochain mais pour répondre à la
question que pose le titre c'est une
bonne situation s'administre je pense
que la réponse c'est oui visiblement ça
laisse du temps libre des nouvelles de
donald trump et de son swing l'ancien
président américain a jugé bon de
publier un communiqué à propos de sa
partie de golf entre amis ce week end
beaucoup de gens me le demande alors je
vous le dis c'est 100% vrai j'ai fait un
trou en un certes mettre la balle dans
le trou du premier coup c'est rare mais
de là à envoyé un communiqué pour le
raconter c'est du jamais vu si vous ne
connaissiez pas poker sachez que c'est
tout chanteuse et influences
brésiliennes et aux 15 millions
d'abonnés sur instagram un réseau sur
lequel elle prend la pose de manière
très naturelle
où elle porte des robes avec son nom
écrit un peu partout pour pas se les
faire piquer
encore de très belles filles savent
qu'ils n'ont rien à envier à celle de
francis lalanne que qu'une bête humains
tant ici elle fait parler d'elle en ce
moment c'est à cause d'une sombre
histoire de flatulences arrest de magnin
tout près à s'exhaler c'est un vers de
racine à reste de chaleur tout près à
cette démo on va voir mais quelle
culture tout ça pour dire que quelqu'un
a pété franchement
[Applaudissements]
voilà bien sur france bleu l'état
[Musique]
j'avais envie de faire mon ciel un dans
ton enfin ou deux dans ta clairière
jean image faut que je l'enlève vite et
wipo cas n'a pas osé faire de paix en
présence de son petit copain préférant
ainsi tout garder pour elle ce qui l'a
conduit à l'hôpital et à faire un
témoignage vidéo poignant
je me suis réveillé j'ai cru que j'avais
l'appendicite j'ai fait un check up
complet et au final c'était un écran
c'est le conseil que j'ai pour vous les
filles ne retenez pas de gaz laisser
sortir tout le monde pète le cul est
fait pour ça rassurez vous tout est bien
qui finit bien car depuis il faut croire
qu'elle se lâche complètement
j'essaie de toujours offrir des bons
goûts mais ne t'amuses même pas j'ai pas
le temps
qu'ils essayent il verra qui récolte le
vent sème la tempête mais lawrence
prochaine tempête en bref le lapsus du
jour nous est offert par fabien roussel
ce matin sur france info
donc quel pays on vit que bernard
arnault baise baisse de deux points sont
son chauffage oui mais c'est parce que
baiser son chauffage j'ai pas aimé ne
pas être super agréable pour qu'on voit
la consommation d'électricité des
centrales edf là où se trouve michel
chevalet il faut il faut que vous
fassiez le même geste que moi si vous
êtes prêts je le suis
attention un deux trois éteignons les
lumières je n'assume pas ce qui se
situait près 1 suivant le conseil que le
gic elle est descendue lumière de ce
plateau alors merci de faire comme nous
à la maison mais laisser la télé allumée
est ce que vous faites vous lui mettez
la télé
oui on regarde la télé ensemble elle
aime bien ça
le soir notamment on la regarde ensemble
parfois je lui montre des images de son
mari elle est contente ça lapèze est
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on allait sur
des ponts habités pourquoi est-ce qu'on
construisait sur les ponts pour être
complet pas de loyer ah oui eh ben oui
c'est pour çà doit on payer pas le loyer
au seigneur et aux propriétaires
terriens aujourd'hui c'est quand on vit
sous les ponts qu'on ne paye pas de ma
vie
il est habile balle au
bond qu'est ce qui vous arrive c'est
horrible come back oui